this episode brought to you by
expressvpn the best VPN there is take
back your online privacy today
[Music]
hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic guy
remember it so you don't have to and
welcome to X month we don't have a
doorbells libary check that out uh yeah
what are you doing here and how do you
make that doorbell sound it's one of his
many gifts so we trust you remember
babysitting our teenage nephew today we
weren't you about five months ago yeah
but I move studios hoping you wouldn't
find me we have eyes everywhere the more
I find out about you the less I somehow
know we don't actually know when are
gonna be done so best play it by ear the
why do you have some important stuff to
do and you can't drag him along with you
no we just don't like spending time with
him is that right buddy I don't care
dude you can't just leave him here
indefinitely so what do you like I don't
care it's the following routine just
gonna be you answering I don't care to
every question
I don't care well if I know modern
parenting just putting a screen in front
of you it's the best way to raise you so
two screens must be better you just play
on your phone while I watch the first
x-men movie x-men
you mean like the Marvel Comics yeah I
love Marvel Comics yeah what do you
think about the Marvel movies they're
amazing they're like the comics come to
life oh my god well you're gonna love
this movie then yeah when this film came
out every x-men fan went nuts so this is
a really great and faithful Marvel
adaptation that's what everyone said at
the time and seeing how that was almost
20 years ago on the landscape for comic
book movies has barely changed at all I
think we're both in for a lot of
surprises
when x-men came out there was little
faith in it with the acceptable ADA
comic book movies at the time was seen
more and more as a big joke
ever since Batman and Robin left a bad
mark and everybody's rubber anuses comic
book flicks were shown very little
dignity and even less ticket sales so
when the loud and bombastic yet still
poignant and challenging x-men comic was
given the big-screen treatment it was
not given much of a budget or even much
credibility even the trailer has sort of
a b-movie sci-fi channel feel to it it
looked pretty corny
but thankfully the movie didn't suck
which immediately meant it was amazing
critics praised how they weren't
laughing at the comic book film which
back then was pretty rare and fans loved
seeing a certain amount of dignity I'll
hell any amount of dignity given to one
of the greatest comic book series ever
made but it's not like Doctor Strange
where they made a ancient one into Altec
woman or like Iron Man 3 were they made
the Mandarin not an alien so annoying
when they change stuff like that well
again I haven't watched in almost 20
years but seeing how people look back on
it so fondly it has to be a great
adaptation and I'm excited so am i let's
go back to the year 2000 when people
really knew how to do comic book movies
this is x-men that means they're aware
of the title mutation the final frontier
we open on a brief narration and we
early 2000s movie I'm guessing quick
fast blurry shit you know this really
was the cinematic equivalent of the
upside down visor every time you see it
you're so glad it's dead and thus we
opened this action-packed comic book
superhero movie with a concentration
camp
nananananana yeah it looks like they're
going all the way with this keeping the
backstory of classic x-men villain
Magneto totally in check with his
parents being killed in the Holocaust
discovering his mutant powers of
magnetism at a young age and creating
his hatred for humanity during one of
the worst times in humanity's history at
a time when the most recent comic book
movie was Mystery Men this was a ballsy
start wow that really is faithful oh you
bet just look at the next scene that
takes place in the not-too-distant
future
when we're introduced to role play by
Anna Paquin only a few hundred miles to
Anchorage rogue uh-huh that's rogue
uh-huh the twenty-something super strong
confident one-liner spewing badass that
sucks people's energy oh close now she's
a teenager who cries a lot is super
depressed and can only suck people's
energy so not rogue hey come on what was
a tortured character yeah but she was
still cool because she was confident she
had one of the cruelest powers she could
never touch anyone without sucking their
life away but she turned that angst into
something kick-ass not taking shit from
anyone socially or physically you could
look up to her because even though you
knew she was suffering she still chose
to be positive and full of hope that's
what made her one of the coolest x-men
sure if you want to be right but this
character has a lot to look up to like
what her angsty face that looks like
she's trying not to cheat her pants
[Applause]
[Music]
now that's something I can be inspired
by see she's inspiring me already okay
in all fairness frogs not a bad
character here she still has death as
active very well it's just not rogue
something continues though we get more
faithful interpretations like Charles
Xavier played by Patrick Stewart Jean
Grey played by famke janssen and Senator
Kelly played by torch Costanza's boss
are mutants dangerous
I propose a poem about Susan's death
this senator thinks the evolution of
humans or mutants as they're called are
a growing threat because their
heightened powers are becoming more
frequent and powerful a girl in Illinois
who can walk through walls now what's to
stop her from walking into a bank vault
okay can anyone really be taken
seriously in front of that Willy Wonka
golden ticket mural she's looking like
the Virgin onatopp what Xavier sees
Kaiser so say oh I mean magneto walking
away he's played by Ian McKellen what
are you doing here why do I ask
questions to which you already know the
answers and which one of us is talking
right now I confuse us both a lot
whatever you're looking for well if
you're looking for mental images in my
head take a gander at this ah there's
plenty more gay Middle Earth porn well
that came from this baby's loaded with a
mime god damn Gandalf meanwhile Rose
powers drain the life out of her
boyfriend
no he just found out he signed down to
three Resident Evil movies and she
leaves her home in the south and runs
away to northern oh bird oh Christ to
hitchhike that far you meet the thumbs
of uma Thurman from even cowgirls get
the blues I thought you said you're
gonna take me as far as Laughlin City
this is law for the city even her plan
take the absolute ultimate had and Jack
Dawson the world on the drawing in a
dream if you could fly that'd make more
sense yeah we know what you think well
maybe this cage fight bar can further
her travels
he can sing he can dance he can host the
Oscars yet somehow he's still a credible
badass this is for King Leopold this is
for pan this is for not getting Russell
Crowe to drop out of Rome is if you're
still disciplined they didn't do rogue
right
check out this introduction did I just
turn gay we all do from frame 1 Hugh
Jackman got Wolverine down perfect it's
the same when Michael Keaton was Batman
or Christopher Reeve was Superman you
didn't see an actor portrayal you saw a
childhood hero come to life sure there's
no mask or costume but the overload of
adrenaline and testosterone is so heavy
it just turned us into steaks I'm a
steak and that's okay he wins the fight
as rogue hangs around the bar not
exactly knowing what to do I love the
beer yeah I hear I was supposed to be
teamed up with this rogue bomb show as
the hots for me and can suck me dry oh
god you're not her are you okay fights
off Steve Wilkos but can't help but
sense teen angst in the air I'm sorry
thought you might help me the hell are
you doing I mean you call that a
southern accent it's not nearly as
consistent as my Canadian accent eh he
does decide to give her a bit of a break
though and the two of them seem to form
a bond
she even over time starts to see him as
a protective role model the first boy I
ever kissed ended up in a coma I can
still feel him that's the same with you
wait a minute an insecure teen runaway
that looks up to Wolverine that's
Jubilee totally rogue it's Jubilee man
now that's two characters I'm never
gonna see done right in the movies like
uh there and there and it may be somehow
okay look clearly they want to do like
what they did in the cartoon with the
young newcomer being introduced to the
team serving as the audience but it's
Wolverine who's focused on when the
x-men are introduced yeah but at the
same time
she has a much more tragic power she
can't touch anything what a great
metaphor for teen angst so change the
power not the character they could have
replaced her with Jubilee and made her
powers blow up everything she touches so
she still couldn't make contact with
anybody in fact Kitty Pryde has a cameo
in this and she's a teenager that can
disappear through walls not being seen
as a far better metaphor for teen angst
you could have done either of those
faithfully and then save rogue for
another movie where she can be older
badass and fly no you listen here young
man I will not have you badmouth well me
and my college friends chose to ignore
whatever I'm gonna go back to playing
tinder fortnight wait you're gonna miss
one of the greatest rivalries ever you
see after a tree falls in front of him
he suddenly smells spear gum in the air
[Music]
oh is that Sabretooth damn right that
Sabretooth one of the greatest rivalries
of all time is Wolverine and Sabretooth
it's been going on for years in the
comics cartoons games
it's a classic feud and now we're
guessing it explored here in the movie
or you runs away like a bitch have a lot
of other characters to establish
establish and ruin I don't like you well
after that Court unquote panel Wolverine
has a much more terrifying nightmare to
face waking up without his clothes and
being back in school while also being
cast in Australia thank you I look
forward to you being recast it twice so
Wolverine is introduced to Xavier and
the x-men who saved him Cyclops played
by James Marston and store and played by
Halle Berry what is up with that wig
looks like got the Queen a dragon okay
look here if you keep laughing like that
you're gonna miss the incredible romance
that rogue cast Oh Jimmy's gambit
[Music]
Iceman is her love interest well
technically it's ice boy what the hell
they're one of the coolest couples in
comic history and you totally could have
made gambit a teenager with how
rebellious he is that would have worked
fine I thought you were an x-men fan and
how are you okay with this
you weren't there man we grew up with
shakka steel it's Dale Xavier shows
Logan that he runs a school for young
mutants it's a little weird that rogue
is just immediately tossed in a class Oh
your runaway who just had your life
button get to history class don't you
even want to call my pen history class
welcome oh it's an ice sculpture of
dogshit hill it's even more realistic
when it starts to melt but the school is
merely a public face
hello a levels however are an entirely
different matter I'm still not sure how
I got government funding for a military
aircraft most public schools can't even
afford the races you know I think it's
the chair I play the pity card pretty
high meanwhile looks like senator
Kelly's off to great more fans but his
helicopter is hijacked by Magneto's
goons a mutant named toe played by ray
park and a shape-shifter named mystique
played by Rebecca romaine I assume she's
not rogues mother why do you ask
questions you already know the answer to
[Music]
my greatest fantasy is terrifyingly come
true they'd taken to Magneto's hideout
at the former location of fire festival
where magneto has plans for him are you
a god-fearing man senator there's such a
strange phrase I'm a gods and monsters
found myself in one of the film's more
brilliant additions magneto makes a
machine that's sort of a gay convergence
reversal where a person is transformed
into a mutant what do you intend to do
to me let's just say God works too slow
I'm going to pray your humanity away the
only downside Christ that is such a
boring looking effect if I was to tell
you a giant beaming cases you and
transforms you and does something else
that you'd be excited to see that this
just looks like Gosar's fishing net it's
actually making me miss sky portals sky
portals meanwhile Wolverine and Jean get
to know each other better where's your
room with Scott down the hall was that
your gift putting up in that guy I mean
he hasn't had a line yet but the comic
says we hate each other I can move
things with my mind really what kinds of
things I also do amazing things with my
thighs but Logan dares her to read his
mind so read my mind I'd rather not she
refuses then that immediately doesn't
what did he mentally convince her and we
couldn't hear it read my mind
Scott look I thought of him naked once
oh you gonna tell me to stay away from
me girl if I had to do that she wouldn't
be my girl so I guess there is a little
development of Cyclops of Wolverines
feud but it once again kind of comes out
of nowhere and isn't focused on much to
feel genuine in the cartoon when their
personalities are so well defined one
always following the rules the other
breaking them but here we know so little
of what Cyclops is like we just know he
wears Tom Cruise shades so I guess that
instantly makes us hate him you know
it's weird that the best rivalry in this
superhero movies between the two old
guys who rarely see each other in the
middle of the night Wolverine has a
flashback about where he came from
rogue tries to wake him but he's not a
morning person somehow she absorbs his
healing power resulting in her
body getting better and I guess the
holes in our PJs - sure she'll be
alright
yeah you're under arrest for stabbing a
student wait I forgot one Hogwarts rules
anything flies in this damn school
meanwhile with Kelly's new mutant
abilities he photoshopped himself free
and swims to shore and I gotta say with
all the cool powers you could have given
him British sunbathing it's not one of
the more impressive ones even Stan Lee
here is like wait when I envisioned
x-men as a movie this is not the imagery
that came to mind meanwhile mystique
disguises herself as Bobby to tell rogue
to take her Fiona Apple wardrobe out of
here where is she oh she's gone she's
gone row I almost said it
Xavier uses a device called cerebro to
psychically locate her oh I do hope this
means more palettes of gray it's not
like the x-men ever have much color in
it
he locates her and Wolverine decides to
steal cyclopses bike to find her
oh that bike is amazing right how many
action scenes is it in well that's what
I thought hey this is exciting at five
they could get to history class
convinces little green Riding Hood to
come home while Cyclops and storm search
for her in the train station we don't
talk to people with you master eyes but
things heat up when magneto and
Sabretooth attack all right so we're
gonna finally see Wolverine and
Sabretooth go at it Oh
Sabretooth is going after storm and
magneto is going after Wolverine it
should be the other way around
magneto and storm should be tossing
things at each other and Wolverine and
Sabretooth should be clawing each
other's faces off we're halfway through
and the greatest rivalry ever hasn't
even been built up at all him and
mystique barely even talk I can see why
they're called mutants because half of
them are friggin mute you do have kids
with your Marvel movies refusing to fix
what's not broken
my day spa took orders from a muppet
aardvark and we liked it well no we
hated it but we liked hating and tell
yourself whatever you want see man I'm
going to watch The Avengers end game
trailer again you know mr. staff isn't
in their phony movie phony movie
where are you well where are any of us
really look you need to come here and
collect your kid he's an absolute menace
really what did he do he's not liking
the x-men movie oh no oh yes you come
here and pick him up ASAP well that's
gonna be pretty tricky critic because I
fell asleep chasing a puppy who
swallowed government secrets yeah
either a fireman I'll come here but the
movie will be over by then there's more
important things than movies critic like
finding a cure for an STD that you
yourself created fine just be here at
5:00 good oh by the way do you know of
anyone who can cure an STD that you need
come darling there's so many more
prostitutes to bring back to life
[Applause]
[Music]
shopping I love shopping I love shopping
I love shopping I love what I just plus
seventy two copies of the smash hit
drama oranges do taxes but I don't even
like sending two copies of the smash hit
drama oranges to taxes unless somebody
hacked my credit card information while
I was shopping online wait a minute that
can happen because I've expressed VPN
without a VPN your credit card
information is wide open to hackers when
you're doing online shopping if a hacker
discovers your information online they
can spend your money and access your
shopping accounts all because you didn't
have expressvpn protection that's
because expressvpn encrypts your
internet data preventing others from
sniffing your information over the
network so you can shop online with
peace of mind
thanks to express VPN they have the
fastest speeds consistently faster than
other VPN providers server locations in
94 countries giving you plenty of
options to choose from apps for every
device including Windows iOS Android Mac
Linux router and more and it's easy to
use you just connect with one click its
internet without restrictions securely
stream or download content from anywhere
anytime it's also the market-leading VPN
rated the number one VPN service by
TechRadar I use it because I shop online
all the time like you probably do and I
want my information protected as much as
possible so that everything's Oh
[Music]
expressvpn is less than seven dollars a
month with a 30-day money-back guarantee
so take back your internet privacy today
and figure out how you can get three
months free by clicking on the link in
the description box expressvpn comm
slash nostalgia critic take back your
internet privacy today with expressvpn
so everything can be
all good expressvpn the best VPN there
is take back your online privacy today
[Music]
hey everybody just letting you know
we're gonna be at c2e2 in Chicago
that's me Brad Jones Rob Malcolm Tamra
and a whole bunch of the channel awesome
gang are gonna be there we also have a
panel movies everybody disagrees with
you on where you get to talk about the
movie that everybody
well disagrees with you on it's your
panel it's a lot of fun we've got the
booth that this kind of ton of times
it's a lot of fun and we'll see you
there
[Music]
so magneto rips the train apart as
Wolverine tries to stop him I'm a giant
soup can you're not my type
I prefer redheads blue redheads
it looks like he's after rogue instead
of Wolverine and he nuts are out cold
always tried to run away from needles
being thrown at them what are we lying
the cops tried to stop them but that's
just awesome
he points their own guns at them but
Xavier controls the minds of Sabretooth
and toad to stop him can't you read my
mind
you forgot my shielded magic helmet
you'll have to kill me Charles I don't
think I can stop them all hey why don't
you use Sabretooth you're controlling at
the moment to take off his helmet so you
can read slash control his mind but the
friggin professor can't figure that one
out as he just lets magneto go I thought
you lived at a school
just be sure you bring her back in time
for history class just that the x-men
are about to go looking for them to get
an unexpected visitor can I interest you
in bigoted Scout cookies well I'm not
saying I'm enjoying this I'm relishing
it so Xavier reads is mine to reveal but
what we already know so it's pointless
to show again as storm tries to comfort
senator jelly donut I'm here oh you know
even storm kind of sucks I mean the
Halle Berry can turn in some great
performances but she's not really an
image of commanding strength you look at
storm and you see a goddess of lightning
a presence that demands Authority this
storm acts like a nervous high school
counselor on her first day normal people
I suppose
I'm afraid can you imagine if one of the
guards and black panther played that
role that would be awesome but then we
wouldn't have Halle Berry's amazing
African accent Logan you can't do this
alone hang on to someone help us fight
with us where are you going it has brown
hair am I allowed to say that sucks you
are it sucks
hard so the senator turns into a melting
sperm as his body rejects the mutation
Xavier tries to use cerebro to find road
but it looks like mystique infected the
machine using oh no green goo that's
always bad in movies Xavier is knocked
out and after let's see two sentences of
Cyclops talking to Xavier in the entire
movie we suddenly get a monologue about
how close they are you still here okay
you've stopped me everything in my life
if anything happens I don't take care of
them ah they cut away before he sang to
him I've been dreaming of the true
love's kiss but Jean used to cerebro to
locate them as magneto readies his Oh
God
GI Joe bomb batteries aren't included
magnificent are you going to kill me yes
Wow he just said it you'll see that
happen in movies his bedside manner is
on par with Arnold from True Lies are
you going to kill me yep
magneto is here Liberty Island objective
is to mutate the world leaders at the UN
summit on Ellis Island you know for the
not too distant future maps are becoming
very impractical II stupid quit I'm
gonna put my face on it you see you see
you see the fight face I made you see
maps
what about Harbor Patrol radar if they
have anything that can pick up our jet
they deserve to catch us or you could
let them know there's a mutant
terrorists of the Statue of Liberty yeah
why are they doing this alone I mean I
know there's prejudice but if you just
say a mutant is about to wipe out the
world's leaders I think some military
would get there pretty quick maybe then
you can fight them with a ton of backup
and not leave an entire school unmanaged
without an adult
oh it's okay every kiss just a nuclear
time bomb not always aware how not to
explode actually go outside what would
you prefer yellow spandex next you'll be
telling me in another Marvel film a
raccoon will be firing a machine gun Oh
yellow spandex gotta love the sick
architect to design this the giant
chickens down to the freakin basketball
court they don't give a shit about the
children's safety imagine some kids just
want to play midnight basketball no
you're the one that's going down
hey you're finding more things wrong
with the movie huh maybe when I see what
kids grow up with with comic book movies
today and how much more faithful they
are I feel a little jealous about what
we got
I mean yellow spandex no that wouldn't
work in this more realistic world you
created but then neither do all these
plot holes that were originally designed
for a bombastic comic universe instead
of a down-to-earth one yellow spandex
would work in Watchmen in Avengers and
eventually even in later x-men movies I
realizing more and more what they chose
to take out and leave in doesn't always
match the style and tone they created
for this universe well I'm sure that's
what they could do at the time why can
they just go all out why didn't they
make a comic book movie we all know
we're gonna see a comic book movie so
why didn't they make a comic book movie
we know what we were in for it looks
like some good actions coming up see
so magneto gets ready to transfer his
power to rogue so she can use the device
to transform everybody into a mutant
draining all the life out of her I'm
still giving my power to the girl longer
temporarily we can know aren't all men
that's why we leave immediately
afterwards the Blackbird lands I guess
not so elegantly sorry you call that a
landing I call that a punchline
thankfully mystique went to mime school
as she stands ridiculously still as they
walk past her and then she takes on
Logan's form to attack they just
recreate with Hugh Jackman does in the
mirror every morning so this fight scene
is a little odd on the one hand the
battle between mystique and Logan is
actually pretty cool and creative Zoe
didn't know spider-man hang up the walls
was one of her powers however the x-men
battling toad seems a little weak
because it's the x-men battling toad who
gives a shit how could they not take
this guy out in a millisecond look at
this storm can control the weather the
breaking weather master of the elements
what does she do I'm gonna go for a
stroll I'll take my time to admire the
architecture and no face my hand
politely gesturing you to stop
gestured they're so pathetic even has
time to do a little dance I love about
the moon and the junior-m Springer of
course the natural energy of an elevator
shaft obviously bring some powers to
life you know what happens to a toad
when it's struck by lightning the same
thing that happens to everything else I
said lines by George Lucas the head for
charm we have to regroup the other one
ain't far away well gee seeing how these
two characters haven't been together for
a while I wonder if one of them at least
I really hope so
okay we're good then make it to the
Statue but magneto uses his powers to
make them act backwards and captures
them Wolverine uses his claws to break
free though and we have the up mmm most
ethically built up fight ever
[Music]
you know it's not even like you even
needed that much between them it's just
an occasional line here or there an
angry glare like in Waterworld or die
hard
we're Total Recall just a little
interaction to build up the hatred
between them and we get none of that one
of the coolest comic book rivalries ever
reduced down to just two guys hitting
each other big friggin warp oh come on
fights not that bad that's kind of lame
it's a battle on top of the Statue of
friggin Liberty yet it looks like a
stage set from the movie Chicago I mean
look at this day that has effect
why wherever did this switch from CGI to
live-action happened I simply cannot
tell Hitchcock did a fight on the Statue
of Liberty decades earlier and not only
did it feel more grand in scale but
somehow it felt like it had more color
than the actual caller movie did but
look he says Bob just like in the comics
yeah that's cool the Y's that look like
the Statue of Liberty has a Wolverine
earring and look after storm warp
whistles him to the top we still have to
see that radioactive eight drop soup
effect almost consumed the city but it
ends on a nice note look a figurative
and literal touching scene where Logan
gives his power to save rogue come on
kid you don't want to miss history class
but look it's nice it almost kills him
so he was willing to sacrifice himself
for her thang yes
actually Jesus this poor guy spends half
the movie friggin passed-out
narcoleptics have their eyes open more
than him so magneto is arrested and
mystique somehow survives three nights
to the chest yeah nobody dies in these
movies and somehow everybody dies in
these movies and she takes over the
identity of Senator Kelly mystique son
of a bitch okay if that I thing was on
screen for a frame and they paused it at
just the right moment I could see maybe
people not catching on to it but look
how long it goes after those concerns
you're turning into Jar Jar Binks that's
absurd I mean everyone Maja's to heal up
and Xavier gives Logan the location of
where he might find some answers about
his past so he's off but not before
saying goodbye to rogue I kind of like
it it reminds me of how I almost died I
don't want you to go
I'll be back for this no I gotta take a
leak and I hate wearing in the bathroom
just hold on to it before I leave you
forever finally we see the only real
rivals in this movie sequel beat the
hell out of this series doesn't even
wake you in the middle of the night the
feeling that someday they will pass that
foolish law and come for you
well it's American politics and nothing
ever gets accomplished so probably not
the wars still coming charms and I
intend to fight it always done less I
died a couple times and or wipe out all
mutants off the face of the earth but
you know these movies are pretty
consistent I can't see that happening
they exit via giant condom and I guess
the most authentic x-men movie has
finally wrapped up Wow you know you were
totally right when you compare it to
comic book movies today this isn't
nearly as impressive as I remember it
well it's okay yeah how as an adaptation
it doesn't have the color imagination or
death of characters as a standalone
movie it's kind of bland with a ton of
plot holes apparently there was 15
minutes cut from it and it really shows
it just kind of feels like we go from
scene to scene with no big emotional
impact ever being made well okay I guess
that's all true but look at it this way
when it came out nobody took comic-book
movies seriously mostly because they
followed the source material even less
than this film did so attempting to be
taken seriously talking about prejudice
while also trying to be somewhat
faithful to a source nobody took
seriously was kind of risky it had to
take baby steps find a middle ground so
that future comic book movies could take
more chances and risk higher budgets
sure the movies just okay but being okay
back then is what led other comic book
movies to being great today even if it
didn't leave as great a story as you
remember it still left a great impact
for comic book movies to follow
yes a good point you know we actually
learned a lot with the different comic
book movies who grew up with yeah I
guess we did
I'll be your uncle experience I thought
it was gonna be I pity the fool he
kidnapped my thorn dad your dad miss
petite there he is
there's the guy that kidnapped your son
it certainly wasn't us because when I
think it certainly wasn't us that is a
foolproof argument come here sucker
we'll kick your ass this is don't words
and this is Joanne so witty any
questions oh yes get the history class
Walker here I'm recording this on my
phone today because the cameras back the
studio someone else was using it but I
still want to do the charity shout-out
and if you haven't heard a whole bunch
of tornadoes have gone through Alabama
and I think something like 23 people
were killed and lots of people are left
without homes and this is a really
terrible tragedy so today we're gonna do
the Red Cross for East Alabama it shows
how you can donate shows how you can
volunteer it's a really really wonderful
site
and the I need Red Cross is great that
they always do wonderful work but yeah
definitely so many people have lost so
much so definitely go donate check them
out maybe even volunteer because there's
a lot of people that need help thank you
so much
you